- Okay. We're back with Karen,
the amazing mom of two boys
and she's looking for
a little design advice
and I would love to give you some.
- Yeah. I mean, clearly I need it.
Look at that.
- Well by the way, you
had a big other change
happen too, recently.
- Yeah, so 2020 again, kind
of the year of change for me,
I went into it
and it was like, okay, I'm
going to turn 40 this year.
I joined a gym in January then of course,
those got closed down in March,
workout videos, thankfully exist.
And yeah, I've lost about
75 pounds this year.
So far in like nine or so months.
Thank you.
I feel good, I feel good.
And that's what matters.
And my kids get to see that.
That's the other thing
they'll talk all the time.
Mommy, you're so strong.
And I knew I was strong mentally
with everything I've gone through
but now as sort of ready to show people.
Yeah, I'm also physically strong.
- I mean at just every single turn,
you are such an inspiration.
I can't handle it, it's like, Karen,
what can't you do?
- I mean, I'm pretty sure we can find,
well, design a bedroom, clearly.
- Well good news!
- I'm not good at that.
- Good news, Karen!
I'm getting on my little design cape
and I'm swooping in.
Now the thing that I really
loved about this room
was the wood.
- Okay.
- And I know that there
is a certain painting
that's very important to you
that actually has a nautical theme
and wood plays into nautical.
- [Karen] Yup.
- [Drew] So let's work
with the wood in your room.
- [Karen] Okay.
- I find the tones a little masculine.
- Okay.
- You know, they're sort of
with the valances at the top
of the curtains, the dark
pillows, the dark chair.
There's some sort of
masculine aesthetics going on.
And I think a little feminine
little lighter colors would work nicely.
- Okay. I think that sounds good.
- Well, we wanted to
actually surprise you.
So this was your bedroom.
- Okay.
- This is your bedroom now.
(Karen laughing)
(audience applauding)
- And the sail boat, no way!
Yeah. Wow.
- Come on up.
You go over there to that side.
- Oh my wow. Wow.
- [Drew] Everything in this room is yours.
- Oh my God.
This is incredible.
Oh my God, this is amazing.
- I have to say, I thought the
painting worked really well
over the bed, but I wanted the chi to
maybe it was right in
front of you every day.
So I thought whereas this
might be a glance over
and a little bit more of
something you fall into
as a voluntary choice rather than
the everyday immediate hit.
I specifically placed
mirrors over here because
of the incredible accomplishment
of losing 75 pounds.
You need a mirror over your dresser
and you need a full length to say like
look at what I've done and see yourself.
- That's awesome.
- Truly see yourself.
We did sconces over the bed
so that you'd have more
space on your bedside table
because the lamps always
monopolize all the table space.
- Yes. I like books holding up my lamps.
- I fell in love with this
company, Serena and Lily,
and they have this beachy
quality about them.
That to me was so transportive
every time I would see their stuff,
it took me on holiday
and they are who did all of
this with us, Serena and Lily.
- That is amazing.
- And then we know that
you have your taste.
They're incredible.
And then nicest company.
And so they are gifting all of this
and Serena and Lily
has taken care of that.
And then the mattress was provided
by Lisa sleep and it's a
King size hybrid mattress.
- Wow.
- [Drew] Very nice.
- Awesome, that's amazing.
- Thank you, Lisa.
Also, because of all
your wood in your room
I thought like a nice bamboo
red, tan, but we had no time
and Three Day Blinds swooped in
and were like, we're doing it for you.
And then Mr. Handyman,
which sounds like a really fun company,
Mr. Handyman is gonna paint your room
because we thought out with the purple,
in with the new, and
they're also gonna repair.
There's a little water
damage on the ceiling.
- They're gonna do that?
Yeah, yeah. That's all done.
- This is incredible.
Unbelievable. I can't, I can't.
I thank you.
Thank you to all those
people you just mentioned.
And yeah, this is awesome.
This is really cool.
And I'm really happy with this.
Like it totally.
This is my, this is what I thought
when I bought that painting,
someday it's going to work
in this room and it works.
It works.
It's awesome.
This is incredible.
- I think that when you are surrounded
in some type of serenity
and beauty, and that can
come at very different prices
for everyone, this is not
a matter of economics.
It's a matter of trying to
have the care for your mental
and spiritual wellness to be in a space
that you feel good about.
- It's incredible.
- Thank you, Karen.
- Thank you, thank you.
(upbeat music)